they build you up
and then once you get there
they're so quick to tear you down
janet jackson is telling her side of the
story
justin and his team have been trying to
contact us about you doing the super
bowl
an extended look at the pop icons
authorized documentary janet is teasing
bombshell moments including jackson
addressing the fallout after the
infamous wardrobe malfunction that
happened during her 2004 super bowl
halftime show performance with justin
timberlake
you've been very private about your
personal life up until now
why did you want to do this
documentary it's just something that
needs to be done the doc which is set to
air january 28th and 29th on lifetime
and a e comes two months after the
release of a new york times documentary
about the headline making moment and the
impact it had on jackson's image
this year seemed like they were trying
to diminish jenna's career
her career gets put on ice and justin is
rewarded e.t spoke with the filmmakers
behind the undressing of janet jackson
who explained why it was important to
them to investigate the moment from
today's cultural lens
we wanted to just look at it from
today's perspective and put it under a
microscope and look at the how and the
why
one person was treated differently than
the other and i just think it made a lot
of sense for me at this time
timberlake issued a public apology to
jackson last year after the release of
framing britney spears made by the same
team as the new york times's jackson
documentary
one of the many things that we took away
from the experience making and releasing
framing britney spears was that there
can be incredible value in bringing
journalistic rigor to subject matter
that others perhaps trivialized
minimized overlooked in some ways it can
be of critical importance to look at an
event that we may realize now we've
misremembered in context to provide
context but back to jackson's authorized
documentary fans can get ready to see
the pop star like they've never seen her
before
there's a great deal of scrutiny that
comes
with having that last name the famously
private songstress will also open up
about her childhood as the youngest
sister of her famous family plus she
addresses how allegations made against
her brother michael impacted her career
guilty by association
because that's what they call that right
the doc promises never-before-seen
footage and also teases interviews with
many famous friends including missy
elliott whoopi goldberg mariah carey and
more she's a legend she's a blueprint
she is a warrior the greatest show woman
[Music]